In the programming
webcast session today.
And today we'll be focusing upon
object-oriented programming.
A lot, some people may be at stage three
already, who are taking Kinnaugh's
course, and who are looking at how
you would do object-oriented design.
And some people maybe may
have not gotten there.
So if you feel like the concepts that
we're talking and the code that we're
sharing with you, if it doesn't make
sense, feel free to pause the video.
You know, make sure you work through
stage three first before you come on and
look at this webcast session.
>> Yeah, come back here.
That will always be here
recorded on the forums and
on the Google Plus
page site [INAUDIBLE].
>> Yeah, so highly recommend it because
we will not go over the basics of
object oriented programming.
We assume that you know the basics
already through stage three.
Because the stage three videos will
actually tell you how you would do basic
object oriented programming.
So this is for people who want to
learn how to apply this or stuff.
If you need more practice,
if you want to see another application,
something a little more real world,
I think will be good.
So that this perfect webcast for the
students who are at that stage already.
>> Yeah, actually I have
a question right before we start.
It's a good thing to start off with.
What is the main difference between
what we've been learning like procedural
programming and then we’re learning now
which is object oriented programming?
>> Yeah, so procedural programming
is step by step instruction.
So basically you start from top to
bottom and that's in a nutshell.
You start everything from top to bottom
and you never go back to the code.
Object oriented programming, you start
from top to bottom but you also go back.
[LAUGHTER] That’s the in a nutshell,
you go back.
You actually take to program,
okay this is what I programmed before,
I want to keep going back and
keep executing this code that I
want you to do, as an object.
And furthermore the main
difference between procedural and
object is that procedures there's
no such thing as objects.
And basically an object is defined as,
it's a state.
It's an entity that contains a state and
it contains actions to
interact with the world.
It's like an outside world or
an internal world like the programming
system, because basically, if I can
give you an example, this is an object.
This is a dry eraser marker.
So the state and the attributes,
it's black, it's cylindrical.
>> It's erasable.
And an action is that I could
actually use this to write.
So I can actually think
about programming,
if I were to assimilate
this in my programming.
In the programming world like in
the computer, I would tell the computer,
this is an object.
And I'm going to tell it, okay, every
object has the ability to hold a shape.
>> Cool.
>> A cylindrical shape?
>> Yeah.
Has an attribute to be black and
it has the ability.
I'm going to write
a function called write so
that each object has the ability
to write by itself and on its own.
So we'll show you right now how
of the application that
we'll be building today.
And how it'd be very,
very hard and very error prone if
you were to use procedural programming
versus object oriented programming.
Do you have anything else to add, John?
>> Not for right now, but will later.
>> Okay, great, so
let's click done here.
>> All right, let’s dive in.
>> Let’s dive in.
I'm just show you in the next 30 minutes
or so, 40 minutes,
of what we'll be building.
So I'll just show you right now.
So basically you seeing
the screen shot here?
So basically, go here, here you go.
>> Very cool.
>> So
this is actually an application
that you can build in Python.
We're going to give you all the starter
code and also this final code as well.
So you can all go back and code along
and try to understand and the parts and
the processes that's involved
in object oriented programming.
In this case, you see it's a simple
program, it's a graphical program.
>> Yeah.
>> So this is actually for a lot of
people probably your first time seeing-
>> Colors.
>> And not just the terminal,
not just a text based interface.
But now we're diving a little bit into
the world of graphical user interface or
GUI programming.
And yeah, there are tons of
libraries that Python has.
So you just have the ability to
use these libraries to be able
to build these sort of
graphical interfaces.
Great, so that is what we want to build.
And our starter code,
this is our starter code.
I'm just going to run our
starter code right now.
It's just this and that's it.
>> That's so-
>> And no, there's no edge collision.
We need to program that in but you can
see that it's a very basic program that
actually goes in and animates a circle.
I'll just say these are balls,
just to make everyone understand that
we're trying to animate
some balls in this swing.
So here are the things that we're
going to go on and talk about and
learn throughout this webcast.
I'm going to to dive in and
talk about the theory on animation and
how to implement animation in a program.
So it's pretty simple once we decompose
animation and what animation really is.
So hopefully after this webcast you'll
be able to understand basically
the magic behind animation and computer
graphics and computer programming.
So any animation that you see, this is
actually the building blocks stuff and
then the details that you'll see in
computer graphics, computer programming.
That's Jonah?
>> Yeah, we're going to dive in
a little bit deeper into the code and
then see actually how these circle
objects are created in Python and
then how it sort of derives from other
classes that we've created like a shape.
And sort of see the nitty-gritty
about how class methods work,
how instances work and
how method overriding works.
I know that you tried these but
we can see it happen live right
in front of us, so it'll be cool.
And then later on we'll see how we can
make this a full-featured program by
making the circles hit that edge and
then bounce back in
a way that's believable.
And anyway that looks
kind of cool in the end.
And that's all doable in
few lines of Python code,
so it'll be fun to see
how it comes together.
>> Awesome, great.
So can we switch back
to just our camera?
>> Yeah.
>> Awesome, great.
So let's talk about animation,
theory of animation, all right?
Jonah, when you were growing up
have you ever used a flip book?
>> Yeah, those are fun.
>> Those are fun, right?
Basically you have a flip book,
stacks of paper here.
You draw something, and then on the next
page you draw the same object, right?
Say a character, like say
Mickey Mouse or something like that.
Then make Mickey Mouse slightly change.
Yeah he dances, and on every paper,
and on every frame,
the image slightly changes.
Not too much, but
just enough to be able to see a picture,
make you believe that it's moving.
So basically animation and
computer graphics in movies and film,
is just a series of still pictures.
It's all a lie.
>> It's all a lie, really, basically.
It's an illusion.
I think it's our eyes cannot,
above a certain point,
like 65 frame per second, our eyes will
not be able to see,
if we, well let's see.
You know those stop-motion cameras,
or those high FPS cameras?
>> Right, right, right.
>> because if it's a high FPS camera,
like at 2,000 frames per second when you
record it, you'll be able to
see things like doing this.
If I drop this, you'll be able to,
at a high FPS camera,
you'll be able to see this because it's
fast enough to see these frames so
that it looks like you got stuff.
But our eyes can not process that fast.
>> If you mean like a high
FPS camera were filming film.
>> Yeah, filming or
filming this pen drop.
>> Right.
>> It will look like this.
>> But
our eyes will just look like this.
Same thing, it's like we're just
basically fooling our eyes because
we can only display at
50 frames per second.
If this was 50 frames per second,
this is an image, this is an image,
this is an image here.
It means that it gives us the illusion
that the picture that I'm seeing in
the frame of the picture is
actually moving, movement.
And that is the whole big
theory of animation right now,
so let's just step back and
reflect on what it means.
Is that animation is really
just series of pictures.
Okay, we have this basic theory.
How do we actually apply it?
With programming,
we basically tell the program,
okay I want you to display
this picture many times.
>> Yeah.
>> In rapid succession.
So basically, what does that mean,
in computer programming,
in rapid succession?
I want to draw a picture
about the same time but
then I just changed
the picture a little bit.
Can I just call that function over and
over again?
Let's say that I have a function
that draws something,
can't I just draw it and
then wait a certain amount of time,
very little time and then draw it again?
Create a function, wait, execute it,
then wait to then call
this function again?
Draw, so that's basically how
they're actually going to
implement animation, so
let's go back to the code.
I'll show you how actual the animation
will work out and don't worry,
we will give you all
these starter code and
when we post our notes in
the discussion forums.
So basically our animation
is basically made up of,
this whole application is made
of these things right here.
This is the constructor.
So again if you, should have been
able to go to stage three or
if you finish stage three, you're
familiar with constructor function.
So whenever we create
an application like this,
an application frame,
I have a construction function.
So it will actually upon option
creation of this application it's
going to actually execute these steps.
So I'm going to use,
so this is, by the way the library
that we're using is called Tkinter.
T-K-I-N-T-E-R.
So basically what this says is like,
I want to call,
I want to inherit a frame object, and
then basically call the constructor for
the frame object.
I'll then put on line 18 self.grid.
I'll then put this whole application,
and make it show.
Because it's not enough
that I create the object,
I need to make it show on the screen.
Then after that great,
I'm going to create all my widgets.
And my widgets is just things that I
want to put onto my application screen.
And in this function,
this create which you will
actually create my CanvasObject.
We're going to be using an object
called the canvas object.
The canvas actually has functions
that help us draw base.
So without the canvas object it
will be harder for us actually,
basically physically access the screen
and then paint the pixels on the screen.
because we will have to figure
out how to do ourselves.
But this library gives us the ability to
draw shapes, pre-packaged, draw shapes,
put picture stuff on it,
put pixels on it, pretty easily.
And then I'm going to
create my canvas objects.
And in there my canvas objects is
actually my circles, my balls.
And then I'm going to call
these function called animate.
Okay, I've created my initial state.
I have certain circles and balls and
then I'm going to actually
call the animate function to
actually start animating this.
So let's go down to the animate
function itself, the __animate.
And by the way, a caveat, __ in Python
means that it's a private variable.
So I'm creating these private
functions as well to tell, yeah,
this is a private function.
You should not be able to,
you should not access
this method animate outside
of the application object.
You should never access that.
So, let's go down to animate.
>> Can you tell us a little bit more
about the difference between private and
public functions?
>> Sure, so private functions and
variables are variables
that need you define in your object
that that's an internal space.
Work space you don't
want other people other
programmers to access it because yeah,
it's internal.
It's similar to, I'll say let's
imagine that an object is a person.
>> Okay.
>> I want to be able to
access the breathing rate of a person.
>> Right.
I don't want to actually literally go in
and take your lung and
[LAUGH] it's crude but
it's kind of like, it's an-
>> Yeah, you can ask them.
>> Can you measure it?
You measure it.
So basically there's probably
a function called like askBreathRate.
And then the person would know, okay,
I'll put my mouth on the breathalyzer
and I'll breathe into this machine.
Versus you just literally taking
my lungs out and examining them.
>> Right, okay.
>> That happens,
there's a whole potential world of
problems that they can run into.
If you were to mess with a persons
lungs directly, that's bad.
Even accidentally,
even if you had the best intentions.
These private variables are private for
a reason.
>> Don't be messing with
other people's organs.
>> Yeah, that's,
I'll say it's a very crude analogy but
I think that analogy works.
>> No, I understand, yeah.
>> Yeah, so that's the reason why we
have this notion of public variables.
These are, okay, public facing
functions that you should use.
Don't mess with the internal
implications that I'm
setting up in my objects.
They're meant to be, they're there and
they're not meant to be accessed.
>> Now, how do you separate them?
How do you separate,
how do you know if something's
a private variable as opposed to?
>> So, as I've mentioned before,
in Python there's this __.
>> I'm sorry, right, gotcha.
>> So, you'll often see a lot of,
if you're diving into a function or
an object, you're liable to see __ in
the function's or object's definition.
That means that these are private.
You should not be playing
around with them.
You can always investigate and
see what they are.
If you're trying to understand
how they're implemented.
Implemented thereafter, but using it?
>> I don't.
>> Stay away from those.
Good question though.
So, animate,
here's the whole animate function.
This is actually the whole
secret to animation.
This is the magic.
This is what,
less than ten lines of code.
>> Great stuff.
>> Right.
So, here we go.
Here's that's, and you're thinking
about it like, wow this is it?
Well, yeah this is it.
It's basically,
here's three stages of animation.
One is,
I update all my object's positions.
In this case, I update their x and
y coordinates.
because we're using
a coordinates system.
This is how we place objects on
a canvas music coordinate system.
So x axis, y axis.
Axis if your own back
to your algebra days,
where you're trying to graph an object.
So, yeah there we go, so you should've
paid more attention in math class.
This actually applies directly
if you understand the Cartesian
coordinate system.
So, I have a function that
says update everything.
Go through all of my objects,
and update their position.
So basically, if I go down here,
updateAll is with my starting code.
I have it all in one circle.
My circleLeft is my coordinate,
is basically my x axis.
And then I'm adding 250
over FPS to number,
what number The circleLeft is already.
So in theory, if I have circleLeft
is equal to zero, the next frame or
the next second,
I move it 250 pixels for every second,
then the next second,
it's going to be at coordinate 250.
So, that's how you update things.
Let's goes back and do a redrawAll.
Now, here's the thing.
This won't count as a canvas.
If we're painting on a regular canvas,
it means that
if you put paint on your
canvas that's pretty much it.
You can't, it's hard to erase the
pixels, or erase the paint, on a canvas.
And that's why we tell them, we tell
people especially in programming,
we use technology.
That's why we use
the term called canvas.
If you paint pixels on the canvas,
it will not go away.
Unless, you tell it to
basically erase it.
So therefore, if you were to paint,
we paint on top of the canvas.
It's not going to look like
the circle is animated.
So, let's actually culling of this out.
I'm not going to clear everything now,
so actually going to run this program.
Self rejoin, so now you can rejoin,
there you go,there you go,
I'm going to do this.
So, I'm not dealing all
the stuff on my accounts,
I'm just costly drawing things over and
over again.
>> Okay.
So.
>> So, it should make a line.
>> It should make a line.
>> See.
There it is.
>> There it is.
See.
Okay.
And, that's not what we want.
Sometimes we want that,
if we were to check what's wrong.
Draw a series of pixels, then we waste
what's on the canvas at every frame.
So, still back here, there we go.
So, basically we draw,
basic cells tell us I'm going to
delete all my existing Pixels and
then I'm going to actually call on
canvas, the kind of canvas over here.
And there's a function
called create_oval and
then you actually feed
it the coordinates here.
And the fill color is the circleColor
and then the width is zero like a iii.
So, then this will
actually draw the circle.
Now, let's go back this is
still how I set up things,
like a class application that's
an object but that's like bullet point
stuff but if we were to not use object
one to program for our object itself.
Joan, I want to ask you okay,
Give me 30 objects.
>> Yeah.
That would be tough.
>> Why would it be tough?
Here's the code to create
this one object here.
>> Yeah.
I mean, we can do that.
We can just copy and
paste, and do it 30 times.
That would be fine.
We could do that.
>> How about if I want to say, okay I
want some of the circles to be green.
>> How many circle do
you want to be green?
>> Well, 10.
10 green circles.
And, I want maybe their
velocities to be different,
I want them to start at
different locations.
Sounds like too much work.
>> Right, right.
>> Sounds like, I want to do something
that could automate that work for
me, to some extent.
>> Right.
So this is in the procedural world.
We don't have any sets of objects,
like internal representation
of an object, right?
>> Yeah.
So, and
here's where the rubber meets the rope.
I know there was a question asked,
what's the whole point?
What's the advantages of
object [INAUDIBLE] primary?
This is it, right here.
If I tell you I wanted you
to create 1,000 objects.
Let's say,
I want you to create a part of a system.
So, sort of like a game.
Write a part of a system.
A thousand objects is nothing, really.
>> Yeah.
10,000 objects.
>> You need 10,000+ lines of code to
actually create all those objects.
Those little circles.
And then, change them.
And then figure out, at 10,000
lines of code, all I want to find,
maybe 500 of those,
I want to actually change the particle.
Look at four or
five hundred of those circles.
You could clearly see, that you're
going to be just lost hunting down,
going through 10,000 lines of code.
It takes way too much much time.
It's not an efficient use of your time.
It's going to slow down your computer,
if you have all these things and
you try and change things on the fly.
If, you know,
500 objects a time or not objects.
500 lines coded at a time,
you try and change them on the fly.
It's going to slow down your computer,
and
it's not going to be a good
experience for the user.
>> Yeah.
>> And that's what counts in the end.
>> Yeah, and
development time will increase.
>> Development time increases.
If you ever want to change anything,
you need to debug.
>> Yeah.
>> That's going to increase.
If you're working with other developers,
they're going to hate you.
>> Yeah, that's true.
>> That's true, right?
Like other developers will say,
all right, great.
You've created this.
Gimme your code to
create 10,000 objects,
I need to work on the user interface.
>> I know.
And they're like, holy cow.
>> Yeah.
You've just gained 10,000 lines of code.
This is not going to work.
>> People will talk behind your back and
be like, it's no abstraction,
your object oriented programming is
>> Yeah.
Exactly, and that's not good.
So now, general work,
I go into how exactly we'd be,
actually convert this implementation
to more of an object oriented one.
>> Yeah, absolutely.
I mean, you guys have run into
this sort of thing before in CSS.
You don't want to style
things on the fly.
It's really similar with object
oriented programming in Python.
So, rather than creating those
four lines of code that you see,
that Mark highlighted you can take
this idea and create an object for it.
So, like we were talking about
earlier we'll make something like
this expo marker except it's going to
be on the computer and it's a circle.
So, what do we think about what's
the most general idea of when
we think about a circle.
So what A circle is a kind of shape,
right?
So, when we're talking
about programming,
we want to think general and
then more specific.
So, we'll start with making a shape,
because let's say later on
we want to make squares.
>> Yeah, good point there.
>> Or we want to make Corgis.
>> They are your dogs, right?
>> Yeah.
>> The shapes.
It's a kind of shape, a dog shape.
But you can still animate.
Or actually,
draw the specific shape of a corgie.
And there's options for
you to draw it out.
>> Anything's possible, but
it's only possibl.e if you
allow it to happen later on.
So, you want to be forward
thinking with your programming.
So, we start with
creating a Shape class.
>> So, let me go back, go here?
>> Yep.
>> So, class shape here.
>> Class Shape.
So we started defining this in
our final version of this code.
And what, what are some
things that define a shape?
So we can think about
where it is on the canvas.
So have balls that move
around the canvas and
they'll be in different
spots as their position.
They're going to have a velocity
which is going to be their direction
as well as the speed.
They're going to have
a certain width and
height, so we want to code
all these things into them.
So this is how we do it.
If you look closely in the code here,
we initialize it.
Whenever we create a shape
we want to initialize it.
And we're going to pass in all these
variables that we just talked about.
We're going to pass in the velocity,
the width, the height, and the color.
The canvas width, the canvas height,
and then its x and y values.
So, we want to create these randomly
because we're just going to put them on
the page, and make them do whatever they
do, and then have them bounce around.
And then it will look fun in the end.
So the way this works is we assigned
the x value of this shape to a random
integer between zero and a canvas
width minus the width of circle.
So this make sure that your
circle is within your canvas.
Because you want to make sure,
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Your circle is where it is.
So make sure that you're
not here on the edge.
The same thing with the Y value.
You want to make sure
its on the page itself.
Then we assign width of the circle
to all the values that we created.
The height, the color, and then also
we pass in the velocity as a list.
Since it's going to be two values.
We want to put in the speed
as well as the direction.
>> So, actually, these are x and y.
So the list velocity is just x and y.
Just x and y.
>> Okay, okay, okay.
>> It tells you the direction and
magnitude as well.
>> All right, so the x and y value's
going to give you the magnitude and
the direction.
>> And the direction at the same time.
And also, I just want to point out,
why would we assign lists.
Velocity is now just velocity
equals velocity here.
And the reason why it's like with lists,
like other mutable objects
that they act like pointers.
>> Right.
>> So you passed in a pointer You're
basically back passing in a reference
to that same, look,
this is getting a little technical,
down that same location in memory.
And if you somehow change that,
things start happening.
So whenever you want to pass
in a list or a tuple or
anything that is mutable, make sure and
if you plan to change that and make
sure that you've constantly like really
make sure that state is preserved.
Patent a copy of it.
And a trick that a lot of Python
programmers will will do is go use
the list function to pass in
the list and the appList function
will create an entire copy
dedicated just for that one object.
>> Okay, that's great Mark.
Actually, I didn't know about that.
>> Yeah, so that's why I add in comments
like, you need to pass in this or else.
Because if you're doing something
in multiple velocities,
somehow they're all the same.
missile like all rockets are sharing or
pointed to the same velocity,
whenever we're going to change one
object, it affects the entire system.
So we always need to make sure
that we're passing in their
velocities that will own
the that one object has.
>> Had that characteristic to it.
>> Yeah, that's characteristic to that.
So this is a big kayak here.
>> That's a great trick.
>> Yeah.
>> Probably a really necessary
trick by this point.
>> Cool.
>> Great, so if we look further down on
this code, we see some methods
that we defined for this class.
>> Shape.
>> So when we use this shape,
we want to have some functions
that we can pull out of it.
So we can call these getters and
setters.
So when we want to,
like Mark was saying.
We want to ask the shape where it is.
We don't want to just go in and
pull out a shape.
We want to have this function
called get velocity,
which will return that list velocity,
which we copied earlier.
>> It's a copy as well,
it's not the direct reference.
That's actually very dangerous,
to actually do it that way
because it's very error prone.
>> Right, yeah, so
you want to pull out a copy of it so
that you can use that and change it.
Or passing back in, that's different.
Without actually messing
up the class itself.
We also have a function here,
we can set the velocity.
So this is going to be
really valuable when we want
to set the initial velocity
of the of the circle.
But then also later on if
you want to change it.
Then we have getting
the position of the circle.
And then we also have a function for
setting the position of the circle.
Do you have anything else you want
to say about this at this point?
>> No, we could move on.
>> Okay, great, all right.
So we have these animation
methods within the shape itself.
So we had defined earlier
the general idea of animation.
But it's going to be a little bit
different for the circle itself.
We want to have the shapes position be
updating as we move through the code.
So the way we do this is we take that
self.x, which is its expedition.
Now we add to it the velocity
divided by the frames per second.
So this gets a little
bit technical here.
I don't want to spend
too much time on it.
But it is going to be how we update
the function as we go through or
how we update the shape
as we animate it.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Do you want to talk a little bit
more about the how this animates
the shape, Mark.
>> Yeah.
>> Further than what we had before.
Basically in a nutshell how we think
about is like for every update call.
Might recall, because we're calling this
update function every few milliseconds
at a time.
To be exact, in this program, it's 16
milliseconds per frame or per update.
So every 16 milliseconds I'm going to
update the x position with a number.
And this number is
inspired by this velocity.
And this velocity tells it, because it
tells us a magnitude and a direction.
>> Okay.
>> because
it tells me where I want to go and
how fast I want to go there.
Okay, so basically I, we'll have more
details that tells us just
why are we dividing by FPS,
but basically it's just
as a It's a good way for
us to, say, give it a velocity of 100.
100 means 100 pixels per second.
I want you to move at
100 pixels per second.
In this case if I divide this by a few
SS we're working in the realm of
milliseconds.
We need to convert that into
the number of pixels per frame.
>> Got you, okay so
basically each time the frame updates,
It'll be that much further and
it's faster.
>> Yeah.
>> If it's slow there will be less
pixels per frame.
If it's fast,
using more pixels per frame.
>> Yeah, that's just yeah you know.
Well if you,
if you're confused on that I would say,
I recommend just to work
it out on pen and paper.
When I was developing this application,
there was a lot.
I had to take a lot of
notes on my cell phone.
I had to draw on my fingers.
Visually see how my enemy thinks.
>> That's what makes it kind of
fun with this sort of programming.
>> Yeah, like the a little bit
differently than you would otherwise.
Cool, so let's dive into-
>> Let's define the circles actually.
>> Yeah.
So now, that we've defined a general
shape, we can get a little more specific
and talk about the actual circles
that we're going to put on the page.
So, this is the fun part.
So, we are going to inherit the class.
Shape.
So the way we do that is, we have
circle and then within parentheses,
we have shapes.
So this means that all the methods, all
the variables that we used in
shape get passed down to circle.
>> And this is actually very efficient.
>> Yeah.
Right this, if I want to change
something into shape, I just I
don't need to change 10,000 things.
So, this actually really helps you
with maintaining your code base.
So instead of,
this was maybe 30 lines of code,
we reduced possibly 10,000 lines
of code to 30 lines of code.
So, it's huge, this is a very
powerful way of programming.
So, what we can do with this is
we actually define a separate
initial start method this in here.
So, it's going to be a little bit
different than the shape object,
where we ask in the velocity with the
height, color, canvas width can say X.
All the same but we're going to change
a couple different variables in here.
So, we have the radius in the center.
So, why does that matter?
If you think about a circle,
what are the two things that define it?
>> Radius in the center, yeah, [LAUGH].
>> It's actually really important to,
especially ,when it's a is a map right,
exactly.
So whenever, whenever your
defining a circle in a plane,
you just want to go where the center
is and see how big its radius is.
Since if you know its radius, you can
know what its going to look like.
So three is just going to be with
the whole circle divided in half.
Because twice the radius is [INAUDIBLE],
very exact which is
the same as the width.
And the center is going to be
the x value plus the radius and
then the y value.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Yeah.
So right here.
>> So
here’s one negative feelings about that.
>> Yeah,
like if we thought out turn out so.
>> Let’s pull this.
>> [INAUDIBLE] right here.
>> Clearly [INAUDIBLE] so
it’s one on the top.
>> [INAUDIBLE] on top.
>> How things we could find out
>> A shape is an x and
>> It's the top left corner, right?
The x and y's, when we define a shape,
in our canvas system,
it's actually the top left corner.
>> Here.
>> Here we go.
We're going low tech everyone.
This is our top left corner,
this is your x and y.
This is our general shape,
this top x mark.
So, the information we have is x over y.
But we want to know the center here,
so how do we get to the center?
>From this little corner.
>> Exactly, so we only know where the
center is and then where the radius is.
So, I've draw a line out here which is
centered on the radius up to the top and
that's the focus of the circle.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
So we got that right here.
So the way we can work through this,
is we have only okay [CROSSTALK].
>> but still on the and the camera here.
>> So, we can find the center by
if you know where the x value is,
and we add the radius.
That's going to give us,
sorry, that's the y value.
If you add the center here, and
then radius, that's going to help
us Identify the center based
on the information I pass in,
same thing with the y value.
Right now, the y value is zero,
so I just have the radius and
that gives us the y value from top.
>> Yeah, so basically
>> You add [INAUDIBLE] y.
You add then your rays here.
And then, you add in your weight here.
And then so
if r going here and then r going here,
this is your center.
r, r because if x and y is there,
basically x that's how you,
in general, find the center for
any circle.
Giving an x,
y position in the top left corner.
And, again, get a little confused.
>> It's a little complex.
We went through that
a little bit quickly.
>> It's just, again, draw it out, and
you'll be able figure out,
this makes sense.
That's okay, I get it.
That's how you can find the center.
>> The best way to do
this is draw it out.
Mess with the math a little bit.
Put some programs in, break it, try to
see what's wrong, try to see what works.
And then, you'll get it right.
This sample code that we'll give you,
we'll definitely give you the sample.
So let's switch to screen code.
So, let's dive back into
the code of somewhere.
So, we can start creating methods for
the circle and one of the most important
ones that's actually in the circles on
the page is this create random circle.
This is going to help us
create a random circle with
a randomized size, randomized velocity,
and randomized color.
So, they have a few variables in here
that help define the maximum and
minimum widths in speeds.
Some colors that Mark defined that you
can change the different colors too.
And then, the width is going to be
random integer between those
two values that we defined.
The height's going to be same as
the width, because it's a circle so
it's going to be circular.
The velocity is also going to be
randomized between the minimum and
maximum that we created.
The colors are going to be randomized.
And then, when we're done, it's going to
return this circle with a philosophy.
With a color, a height.
And then, it's also going to put.
Does this actually put
this on the canvas.
This application.canvas width.
Or is that just pulling out the width
of the canvas that we create?
>> Yeah.
It's just [INAUDIBLE].
>> Okay.
So, it's going to pass in the width and
the height of the canvas as well.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
So, this create_random_circle
is a method, which takes
in the reference to the class and
actually doesn't belong to any object.
That means we can just call it
straight out of the circle.
>> Circle.
Basically, I'll type this in.
>> Yeah, that would be great.
>> Basically,
call this in the rest of our code.
>> Yeah, anyway.
>> Let's say create and do this.
>> Yup, so like when you were working
with Turtle earlier in the course
That was a really similar one.
Where you could do turtle dot turtle and
it will draw a turtle.
This is the same thing, it's going to
be Circle.create_random_circle and
it's going to throw
a circle on the page.
And it's not going to be any particular,
it's not
going to launch any particular object,
which makes it very powerful and useful.
Okay.
And then.
>> Like, update and
draw, go for that, yeah.
>> Yeah.
So, the final method that we have here
is a draw function.
Which helps us actually take
in the canvas object and
we'll draw a circle on
that canvas object.
This goes back to the actual
canvas that's been created.
It takes that white square and
then helps us to Draw
a circle on it by pushing in
the x value, the y value.
Putting in where it's going to be
by using the width and the height,
and then filling it using
the color that we defined.
And is there anything further
that we want to talk about?
>> The update functions here
because we're overwriting.
This is also overwriting
the update function of the shape.
>> Yeah, so
shape has it's own update function.
And we're going to want something a
little bit different for a circle class,
and it's going to update in the same
way but then were going to move center.
Yeah, we're going to
go to center as well,
according to the x value and the radius,
and the y value and the radius.
>> Yeah, because every time you update,
the x and y changes.
So your center needs to update
along with the new x and ys.
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> So that's again, it tells you
how we would use method overriding.
Good example case right here.
>> And I think we have edge collision.
Edge collision, all right.
>> So this is where the magic happens.
We want to have the circle
behave realistically
when it hits an edge, to bounce
off in a way that's believable.
So, the first thing we got to
do is create an imaginary box.
You have a canvas, but we actually need
to create a box that will bounce back
the ball when it hits it.
So we've created a bounding box
that covers a circle itself.
So when that circle hits
the bounding box, the square,
then that's how we know
the collision happened.
Now we can make the bounce happen.
So say for the edge on a canvas, if edge
is at or beyond the edge of the canvas.
Sorry, if the edge of
the circle is at or
beyond the edge of the canvas,
we can say that the edge collides.
And therefore we can change the velocity
to have the object bounce back towards
the inside of the canvas.
So you have it up?
>> Yeah.
>> Collision.
>> We're right here.
>> Okay cool.
So the way we can check is,
we pass in the object.
We pass into canvas,
the canvas width and the canvas height.
So we check the top and
the bottom edges.
And if the object y is less than or
equal to 0,
that means it's hit the upper-left
corner of the canvas.
And then if you want to check whether
the bottom of the bounding box collides
at the bottom edge of the canvas.
We do the y value of the object
plus the object height, and
check whether that's greater than or
equal to the canvas height.
And now we know that
it's hit the bottom.
>> So what happens when we hit the edge.
How do we set it to bounce back?
>> Okay, yeah.
So when you hit the edge you want to
change the velocity of the function.
And the way that bouncing works,
we just want to change the y value.
Let's say it's bouncing up.
If we hit at the top we
want it to bounce down.
So basically we're exchanging the y
velocity from something that's positive
to something that's negative.
>> Yeah, we're just inverting it.
>> Inverse it, yeah.
And then, what exactly?
Yeah, so if it's bouncing down it's
going to be negative and going back up.
So it's going to be an inverse.
So we want to change
the velocity of the y to
something that's negative
of the velocity of y.
It's going to flip that, change.
And we're going to do
that also with the x.
So if it's moving sideways, now we're
going to change it when it hits the edge
and it'll bounce straight back.
So this means that if we're moving
even obliquely, it's going to
help change it in the way that's exactly
opposite the way that it came in.
>> Yeah, because the x and
y are both changed.
They're both inverse,
so it will go back.
This goes here, hits,
it will just go here.
>> And yeah,
that's actually very straightforward.
>> Pretty straightforward.
A lot of people get
tripped up with data.
If they're thinking like,
how do you collect it?
>> Right, what if it's spinning?
>> No if, you don't have to worry that.
>> You don't have to worry about
these things, like where it is.
Again like how a program works,
it's like you got this big problem.
Just decompose it into like
small little components.
And then just deal with
small things one at a time.
Like say, just collision on the canvas.
You don't need to worry about
collisions in the circles, or
even if it's spinning.
Like say, what's the angular velocity or
angular momentum?
I'm like okay,
well that's a whole different function.
To check to make sure,
okay if it's spinning, okay, I need to.
My update my function
catches the pictures and
I need to update my function
based on what vectors
of the spectre here,
also this angular factor here.
So we need to figure out how to do that.
>> So I need to take physics, more.
>> That's all physics, really.
This is actually a real-world
application of physics.
And this is how you like, model things.
>> Yeah.
>> That's really, you know,
if you're interested
in game programming.
>> Yeah, it's huge.
>> This is huge, and this is where you
need to start thinking about hops to
pick up extracting in terms
of 2D space and 3D space.
And also understand the physics
of objects when they collide,
when they spin.
All the things that you talk about
when you're modeling a system
in the physical world, we use that to
model our systems in the computer.
So just an FYI for our people who
are interested in game development and
actually programming game engines,
and this is a good sneak peak.
>> Yeah.
>> Sorry.
>> You're going to be
doing a lot of this.
>> Yeah.
>> A lot of arrays, a lot of vectors,
a lot of, you know
>> Cosines, tangents.
Yeah, lot's of vector decompositions.
Lots of linear algebra too, actually.
>> Good stuff.
Good stuff.
We're almost out of time, so
let's bring it all together now.
So let's go back to the screen sharing
>> Mm-hm.
>> So
in this code we have all these objects,
and let's go back to really the basics
of like, how this application works.
I create my widgets,
I create my canvas object, and
then I create my circles,
and then I animate them.
So let's go back to
Create_canvas_objects.
I'm going to create ten random
circles to bounce around.
So basically I just have a for
loop, and then I tell them, okay.
I have a list that is
an internal list that contains
a reference to all my circle objects.
So basically, I'm going to, for
every iteration I'm going to
create a random circle, and
then add into my memory and
I'll be able to access it later on.
>> It's that easy?
>> It's that easy.
So basically I could do this.
I'm fine, that's it.
So 10,000 objects?
All right, that's great.
I will probably crash right in my memory
right now, but I'll just go back to ten.
So let's do 50 right now.
>> You're crazy, Mark.
>> I am crazy.
And then the animate thing,
it's still updateAll.
The updateAll function, let's see.
>> updateAll?
>> Yeah, the updateAll and the redraw
functions are slightly different.
because now for every object that
I have created in my updateAll,
I will check whether
that object has collided.
Okay, change the Change of velocity.
I added a feature,
feature to check for circle hood.
So if the balls collide
with one another,
they should react and
bounce away from the [INAUDIBLE].
That has not been implemented yet
so, and
though I will show you how one looks
like if you actually implement it.
In this then you just call update.
And, like, okay, I'm just going to.
After I complate all my coalitions,
I'm going to update the position now.
And based on the need
factors that I've complated.
Same thing as in redraw here.
As you can see, for every object
I'm just going to drop the object.
It's a very simple way for me to
communicate with you what I'm doing.
So hopefully everyone could understand,
okay in terms of objects.
Let's see.
Sorry, that's okay.
In terms of objects.
>> I don't think those
screens should come up.
>> I need to code that, messaging.
Let's see,
let's go back I need to screenshot that.
And so let me show you.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Turn screen.
>> Whoa!
>> Whoa.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Yeah, so basically, if we.
So it's yes.
Just a way for me to draw and
talk in terms of very Intuitive ways.
What I'm talking with another programmer
when I'm trying to think abstractly in
terms of how I'm moving those.
Not just how I'm going to draw them.
I'm going to check the collisions and
I'm going to change them and
then you see,
you abstract all of the details away.
So the code is very real.
>> Yeah.
>> And very maintainable.
>> If you want something else,
you can do it right there.
Yes, not that much harder.
So long do more objects or
different objects can
append different sorts of
objects in once you create them.
So it makes life easy.
>> Makes life easy.
So this is 50, this is over 50 random
objects, random circles that I created.
So yeah, still works pretty well.
>> Cool stuff.
>> Cool stuff, and let's see.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Let them call to the code,
where's that code?
>> What's the bonus round?
>> The bonus round, final.
So basically this one will have,
oops let's see.
No.
Licenses as a typo.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Okay.
Bonus round, here you go.
There you go, so
once you've updated the function to do
object to object illusion this
is what it will look like.
And this is the secret
the key of actually trick and
what you do in this like can you imagine
procedural program you have to literally
check every single object.
And literally calculate
the collisions and the vectors for
every single object at every single
time at any given point in time.
>> There's no point having
computers if you have to do that.
>> Yeah so you get the computer to
actually handle that for you so
with actually the programming.
You just basically program like that
the object itself will say I have
a function, I'm going to look out for
myself if I can, why would anyone else?
I'm going to change my vectors and
my path based on my own collision.
My own way, so
you don't need to like think of it from
a top down approach,
you can think of it from a bottom up,
bottom base approach these
objects are self-contained and
they kind of act on their own.
It's kind of like your programming
an army of things that can think or
act on their own, with you not
having to, track every single thing.
>> You just give them guidelines.
>> Just give them guidelines and
then they'll just go ahead and do it.
Hopefully this gives you a really
good application to play around and
also to think about object
oriented programming.
So if you have any Last minute thoughts,
Jonah,
on object-oriented programming
in general or what we did?
>> I thought it was a really cool start.
I thought that that analogy to the video
game programming was really good.
I mean, object-oriented
programming is going to be
important in anything that you do.
>> Any big project.
>> Yeah any big project, any
>> Even in life, I think.
>> In life, wow.
>> Think a little bit bigger here.
It's good to,
isolate certain tasks like,
let's say in the mornings
I'll go through and
do all the reviews but have it at,
isolated at it's own task and
then I'll think to myself,
this reviewer needs to have an email.
It's already a pre-defined set of tasks.
I don't have to think
through it every single time.
>> Yeah.
>> There's little things that I change
each time but if you think about
abstraction, in a greater sense it's
useful to apply to on
a lot of different things.
It's kind of cool to
see I can play here.
>> Right, yeah.
So, my final thoughts is, object logic
programming is a little weird at first.
But it's, I'd say at the end,
if you're thinking big you'll be
basically programming the computer to
take care of all the little details for
you and make a system that each object
will be able to take care of itself.
And it knows what it needs
to do on its own and
it knows how to update its own state.
You don't need to literally go through
all your objects every
time a state change.
There's one change of state for
one object.
You just program it in a way that the
object itself will take care of itself.
>> That's what makes computers powerful.
>> Yeah, that's a really
powerful way of thinking, and
you Once you get it, it will stay there.
It won't go away.
Okay, great.
Thank you everyone for
>> [CROSSTALK] Thank you everyone for
coming and staying.
And we'll post our notes and
this example code so
you'll be able to play
around with it yourself.
>> All right.
See you guys next time.
>> Bye!